all right metal gear solid 5 is out in
just a few weeks our review will be live
this Sunday but until then fans of
snakes are getting pretty excited and
what am I most looking forward to why
all the new bosses of course
Kojima is amazing at making memorable
bosses amazing ridiculous dumb bosses so
this list isn't some tired ass list of
best bosses like what our website would
do that it's 2015 that's an SEO hand and
[ __ ] it's been done a thousand times
and we know what they are anyway it's
like for wolf the end the sorrow the
boss and Psycho Mantis is the best one
no this is the list of the weirdest
bosses the five times even cause Yuma
jumped the shark
maybe he had too much booze that night
or saw something dumb in a movie or
maybe just wanted to hang out with some
models in any case these are the five
most ridiculous bosses in the history of
Metal Gear and believe me cutting this
down to five was no simple task number
five the pain all right I want to talk
to you about the beginning of what many
consider is the best Metal Gear Solid
game Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater all
in all the first few hours of the game
are pretty grounded you halo jump out of
a plane say hi to some alligators and
attempt to exfiltrate a scientist pretty
standard spy stuff that is until you
attempt a backtrack across a rope bridge
and a cutscene kicks in you know some
shits about to go down and your mind is
racing for ideas
now rope bridges are a pretty common
sight in movies and games so there are a
bunch of things that we assume might
happen here one the other side of the
bridge could have enemies on it too
somebody tries to cut the bridge before
you cross or three gets a bit windy and
it's kind of scary and stuff remember
this is a car Jimmu game so anything you
expect to happen won't happen and
something you never thought was possible
is probably just around the corner say
for instance a man made of bees
attacking you from a helicopter the pain
is a two meter tall soldier who's
capable of controlling Hornets not only
to mask the sound of approaching
helicopters pretty specific use case
really but also to murder people with
the power of bees he can also shoot them
from his mouth like bullets which is the
opposite problem Nicolas Cage had in the
wicker man
because really when you create a
character who's a nest for insects why
not have him be able to shoot bees from
his mouth like bullets they act like
real insects too so if you wear white
camouflage the Hornets will completely
ignore you much like the rest of society
number four sobbing robot wolf 80 with
the Beauty and the Beast unit Metal Gear
Solid four not only amazing because
they're essentially in the game because
Kojima wanted to hang out with a bunch
of models you know the feeling Kiefer
but also because every one of them is
conceptually ridiculous
they consist of floating mind puppeteer
with tiny insect babies and ink spewing
future robot octopus who finds death
hilarious and a giant bird controlling
shaman who won't stop screaming about
that it's software game nobody bought
but my favorite is crying wolf because
the first time I saw her she made me
feel sick to my stomach just freaked the
hell out and completely uncomfortable
why because she's a lady hidden inside a
robot wolf suit who will not stop crying
as she's murdering people she's just
sobbing wailing uncontrollably with this
fucked-up digital voice and also she can
smell enemies because of some future
robot computer reason the Kojima made-up
you know wolves people fear what they
don't understand and to this day I fear
and do not understand crying wolf maybe
it's because I hate people crying
maybe it's because I'm scared of wolves
or maybe it's because in her backstory
she killed a bunch of children in an
African refugee camp but I guess I'll
never know
number three president solidus solidus
snake your dad was the President of the
United States
he wears a dr. octopus suit and shoots
missiles and you sword fight him on the
top of the US Treasury Building I mean
yeah that's that's all I got for this
one [ __ ] weird
number two vampire man vamp is pretty
cool or at least he was in Metal Gear
Solid four when he danced on write-ins
chest at one time otherwise he's sort of
a dumb future version of a vampire he
regenerates health he drinks blood he
can walk on water he can run on walls
he's from the same country as Dracula
vamp vampire yeah we get a cosmic makes
sense but actually wait white not really
that's what lamp is a member of dead
cell born in Romania his specialty is
knives but I guess you know that by now
when he was just a kid and he lost his
family to a terrorist bomb that went off
in a church they were attending his body
pierced by a crucifix vamp was buried
under the rubble for two days before he
was finally rescued during those two
days he survived by feeding on the blood
of his family to quench his thirst that
was how he acquired a taste for blood so
that's why they call him ma'am
no vamp isn't for vampire it's because
he's bisexual yes despite the fact that
he's an immortal Romanian blood drinking
dude who looks like a vampire and talks
like a vampire
he's called vamp because he likes to
kiss both boys and girls proof that even
when you think you know where Cosima's
pulling his ideas from you actually have
no idea also if anyone can let me know
who calls bisexual people vamps I'd
really appreciate it
I think I might have missed that lesson
in bigotry 101 or maybe I just don't
understand Japanese culture oh [ __ ]
Internet minefield I'm out of here so
here we are number one you probably
already disagree with 5 through 2 so
let's go for the full
who is the weirdest boss in Metal Gear
could it be the weird tea party dude
from the end of rising or running man
the Olympic sprinter from Metal Gear 2
or fat man the wine-drinking
rollerblading bomb disposal expert or
maybe the end a 100 year old sniper you
can kill by not playing the game and
allowing him to die of old age nope the
weirdest boss in Metal Gear Solid is so
dumb
that even Kazuma himself found it too
dumb and changed his mind in a later
game in Metal Gear Solid 1 you defeat
liquid snake and revolver ocelot has his
arm chopped off but at some point he hit
liquids arms stuck onto his stump and
was apparently possessed by the arm have
no intention selling middle gear did you
miss that yes he had his dead friends
arm grafted onto his and was possessed
we know this because he spoke with
liquids voice in Metal Gear Solid 2 you
know who I am not so young anymore a
snake but by the time liquid Ocelot
returned in Metal Gear Solid 4 karma had
read conned the story with some [ __ ]
about Ocelot using hypnosis to become a
mental doppelganger of liquid who only
appeared when Solid Snake came over for
tea but I I live on through this job so
the Honda arm story into was so
ridiculous that even Kazuma had regrets
and decided to rewrite history for his
latest game I'm taking it back
will he do the same in Metal Gear Solid
5 will we see even more ridiculous
bosses I sure hope so come back this
Sunday the 23rd to see our review from
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain and
for continuing coverage of the wonderful
world of Hideo Kojima stay tuned to game
spot calm
you